[MUSIC PLAYING]
MIKE TRUTY: Hi.
My name's Mike Truty.
I'm a cloud technical
curriculum developer
for Google Cloud Learning.
And this is Dan Sullivan,
who is a principal engineer
and software architect
in his day job.
Dan is also the author
of the recently published
"Official Google Cloud Certified
Associate Cloud Engineer Study
Guide."
We think there's never been
a better time for you all
to get Google Cloud Certified.
And we're here to
tell you how to do
it using the path, programs, and
tools provided by Google Cloud.
There's a whole bushel basket
of information we have for you.
So let's get started here.
I'm going to try to give you an
overview of our certification
process and then Dan's
going to give you
a little bit of a deep dive
using the Associate Cloud
Engineer Certification
to help guide you
for some strategy on
how to get certified
with concrete examples.
Finally, we're
going to point you
at a whole bunch of
resources and offers
we have available
here at Cloud Next.
So you're here at Next 19.
And I know you're as excited
as I am about everything
getting announced.
And we know businesses are
moving to Google Cloud Platform
to add more value, whether it's
in meeting your existing needs
or inventing your future.
And to support you,
Google has created
two different certification
levels, associate
and professional.
Within these levels,
Google offers
one associate
certification and five
professional certifications.
The two different levels
provide different entry points
for engineers with varying
degrees of experience.
And I'm going to explain that
in a little bit more detail
in a minute.
The different
certifications that we offer
map to different
critical job roles
all contributing
in important ways.
And we have an associate cloud
engineer, a professional cloud
architect, a professional data
engineer, professional cloud
developer, professional
network engineer,
and our newest certification,
the professional security
engineer.
And we're offering our
first public testing
for the security engineer
certification here at Next.
I encourage you all to go to
cloud.google.com/certifications
and explore.
If you remember nothing
else from us today,
that's probably the best
thing for you to take away
is that link right there.
So why certify?
To be sure there are many
reasons to get certified.
It's not horrible.
And we've heard this
from many sources
that becoming Google
Cloud Certified
can increase your earning power.
And I can tell you from
personal experience on LinkedIn
that I get a lot
more attention now
that I've been cloud certified.
So that's pretty nice.
Also since Cloud is about
moving past traditional IT
and unlocking new
paradigms of work,
we know many businesses are
facing a severe shortage
of skilled labor.
And certifications are
a reasonable method
organizations use to validate
baseline capabilities
with a new way of working.
Being Google Cloud
Certified means
you've demonstrated
the necessary skills
to leverage Google
technology in a way that
can transform businesses.
Quoting from IT Skills surveys,
overall, decision makers
reported that certified team
members troubleshoot issues
and complete projects more
quickly and have fewer skills
gaps.
And here's where we
can introduce training.
We know training is separate
but supportive of certification.
And training is
absolutely associated
with job satisfaction.
So this second link
cloud.google.com/training is
where we describe all the
different offers that Google
has for training along
multiple learning paths.
The learning paths
are each mapped
to a different certification.
So the learning paths include
cloud infrastructure, data
and machine learning,
application development,
and so on.
We also offer for training
different learning environments
to customize the training for
whatever you like or need.
We have on demand
courses where you
can learn online at your own
pace wherever you are or you
can get matched with
Google Cloud instructors
and classroom instruction,
which frequently works better
for larger groups.
But perhaps the most
valuable kind of training
experience that we have
is hands on training.
And for this we have
Qwiklabs hands on quest labs.
And Qwiklabs are easy to
work through guided tours
of the capabilities needed to
be successful in these job tasks
and job roles.
So this week here
in the dev zone,
we have a couple of
different lab experiences
that we'll talk
about a little later.
I want to dive just
a little bit deeper
into a question we
get asked frequently,
which is what is the difference
between the associate level
certifications and
the professional level
certifications.
And one way we
distinguish between them
is the associate
cloud engineer is
a job task based certification.
And the professional
level certifications
are job role based, job
task versus job role.
A job task based
certification is focused
on technologies and tools.
That's a good spot
for people who
are trying to find an entry
point into cloud or even
into GCP.
And it's also a great
pathway to our professional
certifications.
In this case, we can see that
for associate cloud engineer,
we use words like build,
and deploy, and manage,
because the job tasks for
that associate cloud engineer
are usually centered
around translating
technical requirements
into technical details
and implementations.
And that's different than our
professional certification,
which adds a couple
of different verbs
like design, plan, and optimize.
And it usually takes many
years to acquire the experience
necessary with the ambiguities
of real world problems
and hands on work to develop
the abilities we look
for translating
business requirements
to the technical requirements
needed by a professional.
That's different
than what we consider
in the associate level.
Now specifically, to
dive a little deeper,
there are proven
strategies to guide you
whether you're pursuing
associate or professional
levels.
So Dan is going to
get into that here.
DAN SULLIVAN: Thank you.
Thanks, Mike.
If you've decided you
wanted to become certified,
probably the biggest
hurdle you're going to face
is actually passing
the certification exam.
So I'd like to
spend a few minutes
and just share some
tips and advice for how
to prepare for the exam,
how to take the exam,
and what you should focus on in
terms of domains of knowledge
and topic areas.
Now I'm going to talk
specifically about the cloud
engineering exam.
But at least half of
what I'm going to say
applies to any of the exams.
And a lot of what I say for
the cloud engineer exam also
applies for the
architect exam as well.
So first of all, I want to
talk about a study strategy.
So if you've just decided
you want to get certified
and you're wondering what's
the first thing I should do,
I would say go to the
certification page
for the certification you're
going to take and find
the exam guide.
Google has done
a really good job
of developing a one page
summary of what's covered
on these certification exams.
Now in the case of the
cloud engineering exam,
there are five high level areas.
And it's things like
planning, deploying, securing,
the [? burbs ?] that
Mike was talking about.
And for each of
those domain areas,
there are very specific tasks
that you as a cloud engineer
should know how to do.
And they get very specific.
For example, how do you expand
the CIDR block on a subnet
so you have more IP addresses?
It's that level
of detail that you
need to know when
you take this test.
So if you're not sure,
and even if you are sure
you're in good shape,
I would suggest
taking the practice exam.
Google has a 20
question practice
exam which is available
from the certification page.
And they give
detailed explanations
of why an answer is
correct or incorrect.
So it's really helpful to
identify your weak areas.
Oh, and one last thing,
if I say nothing else,
probably the most
important thing
is that whatever the
tasks are and however
familiar you are
with certain things,
it's important that you actually
have hands on experience.
So I would say get
into the Cloud Shell,
get under the Cloud Console,
and do these tasks manually.
This is not the kind
of an exam that you
can pass by just reading a
book or reading documentation.
Now if you haven't
been in school awhile,
you haven't taken
an exam in a while,
you might wonder what
it's going to be like.
Well, the exams are all online.
They are multiple choice.
15 questions.
You have two hours
to take the exam.
And one of the nice things
is that you can go back.
You're not locked out
once you submit an answer.
So you can mark
questions for review.
You can go back,
read things over.
And I find that's really
helpful when I take the exam.
I kind of blow through the
ones I know right away.
And the ones I'm going to
have to read and think about
a little bit I go back for.
And then the key thing
about taking the exam
is it's really important to
read the question carefully.
Now I assume that every word in
that question means something.
And what I look for in addition
to just understanding what's
the question asking,
I'm also looking
for are there names of
any services or software
that I should be
paying attention to.
And what are the
technical requirements?
So for example, if I see a word
like or a software like Apache
Spark and then I
also see a reference
to customer requirement
wanting a managed service,
I'm immediately going
to think of Dataproc
and I'm going to start looking
for answers that have those.
One of the things I've found
taking these various tests
is when it's a four choice
multiple or four choice option,
I can usually narrow it down
pretty quickly to two options.
So one of those is correct and
one of them is a near miss.
Now what I do at that point
is I will look and figure out
exactly what the difference
is between the two options
and then go back to the text
of the question to figure out
what's the distinguishing
characteristic
in the requirements
that's going to help
me decide between those two.
So for example, if I've narrowed
down the options to a question,
say picking a database,
and it's going
to be either Data Store or Cloud
SQL, I'll go back to the text.
And I'll look for a
requirement that says something
about maybe a flexible
schema in which case
I'll look at Data Store, or if
I require SQL, then of course
I'll look for Cloud SQL.
Now in terms of what
you need to know,
I think there's two levels here.
There's stuff that you really
need to know in depth and stuff
you need to be familiar with, be
able to understand at a higher
level.
So we'll cover both of those.
So with the cloud, as you
probably heard over and over
again, it's security first.
So when you go into that
cloud engineer exam,
it's really important that you
understand identity and access
management or IAM
and networking.
You really just have
to have that down cold.
And for IAM, the key thing
to understand is that--
excuse me.
The key thing to understand is
the roles and the permissions
and how those are structured.
Now prior to IAM,
Google had something
called primitive roles.
So if you've seen
things like owner,
editor, viewer, these
very coarse grained roles,
those existed prior to IAM.
So did something
called access scopes.
They're still around.
Those are considered--
in the case of the roles
are considered primitive roles.
And in general it's best
practice not to use those.
Best practice is to use IAM and
use fine grained permissions
and roles when you're
implementing your authorization
controls.
On the networking side of the
world, the key things to know
are virtual private clouds.
You just need to understand
what those are and the component
structures within them like
subnets and CIDR blocks,
which are used to
specify IP address
ranges within the subnets.
Fire rules are
important to know.
Also understand
different options
when you're working
with a hybrid cloud.
How are you going to connect
your on premise network
to the Google Cloud?
And so you want to
understand things
like direct peering and VPN.
Also in terms of
things you really
need to know in depth,
definitely cloud and storage
options--
excuse me-- compute
and storage options.
So with Compute Engine,
you almost certainly
want to know when to use
preemptable machines.
You want to understand what
is an instance group, what's
an instance template,
and why do you use them.
You want to make sure you
understand the role of load
balancers and auto scalers.
With the App Engine,
you want to understand
that's a platform as a
service and that there
are two types or two
versions of App Engine now.
There's one called
standard, which
is the one that's been
around the longest.
And that's basically a
language specific sandbox where
you can run your application.
And then there's also
App Engine Flexible,
which allows you to
bring your own container.
So you have much more
control over setting up
your runtime environment.
Kubernetes is really important.
It's getting even
more important.
So when you take the
cloud engineering exam,
makes sure you
understand both the G
Cloud and the Kube
control commands that are
used to manage Kubernetes.
Also understand the architecture
at a high level of Kubernetes
and how it works, and
understand the idea
that services are implemented
through deployments.
And deployments are implemented
within pods which run on nodes.
It's important to know
that kind of thing.
With regards to cloud
functions, those are very short
running pieces of code.
And they're really designed
for event processing.
So if you have a question about
a customer uploading an image
to cloud storage or someone
dropping a message on a Pub/Sub
queue, and you need to do
something in response to that,
cloud functions might be
the right option for that.
Now on the storage side,
it's important to understand
cloud storage in detail.
A topic that comes up
over and over again
when I'm reading various
things about cloud storage
is the different
kinds of cloud storage
with regards to multi-regional,
regional, nearline,
and coldline.
So you want to make
sure you understand
what all four of
those categories
are, when you would use
one versus the other.
And also you want to
understand the lifecycle.
So for example, you
can go from regional
to nearline to coldline, but
you can't go from coldline
back to regional.
Those are the kinds
of things that if you
have that kind of
information in mind,
you understand the
restrictions on various things,
it can help you answer
questions more quickly
because you can eliminate
some of the answer options.
Cloud Pub/Sub is a
messaging system.
So it's important to understand
just messaging structure,
why it's used in microservices
and things like that.
It's not a complicated topic,
but it's definitely worth
studying.
Stackdriver like
Kubernetes is becoming
more and more important.
And Stackdriver actually
has three main components.
It's a logging service.
It has a trace service
and also a debugger.
So you want to understand
each of those three
and how they're
different and when
you would use each of them.
Now those were the
things you really
need to understand as a
cloud engineer in depth.
You also need to
understand at a high level
all of the services that are
available in Google Cloud.
So while you wouldn't
expect a cloud engineer
to know how to,
say, optimize a data
model in a relational database
or design a document data
store, but you do need
to understand when
you would use each of those.
So for example, if
you hear that you
need a relational database
or SQL is required,
you need to know that your SQL
options are Cloud SQL, Cloud
Spanner, and BigQuery.
And then you eliminate--
then you can narrow it down from
there in terms of your options.
If something
requires-- if you need
relational and
global transactions,
well, then you're going
to use Cloud Spanner.
If you're looking to build a
data warehouse or some kind
of analytic application and
you want SQL for data analysts
who like to do ad hoc
querying, then BigQuery's
the appropriate option there.
So just understand
for example Bigtable
If you're talking about
IoT or any application
where you need streaming
high volume ingestion
low latency rights, that's
a great option for Bigtable.
Now you also want to understand
some of the services that
are used for moving data around
like Dataflow and Dataprep
and then also [INAUDIBLE]
some of the data
and analyzing data
like Dataproc.
So Cloud Dataproc is the
managed Hadoop Spark Service.
Cloud Dataflow is Google Cloud's
implementation of Apache.
It's a unified platform for both
batch and stream processing.
Dataprep's more like
an ETL tool which
lets you work with your data
and prep that for ingestion.
Datalab is used for data
analysis, data exploration,
and then there are several
others like Deployment Manager
and developer services,
which again you
don't need to know in
depth, but you just
need to understand what they
provide, and where they fit,
and how to choose between them.
With that, I'm going to
turn it back to Mike.
There we go.
MIKE TRUTY: Thanks, Dan.
OK.
So as I mentioned, you can get
cloud certified here at Next.
You can register online with
our certification pages there.
We've got testing times listed.
And the certification test
will happen across the street
over at the Westfield
San Francisco Center.
And the easiest way to find any
of this information I'm about
to give you is using the
Google Next mobile application
or the online app there
at cloud.withgoogle
.com/next/sessions there.
And you search on certification.
After you complete your exam,
there's some pretty cool swag
that you can get.
And you get to go into the
certification lounge, which
is right there.
So if you are certified,
feel free to go
use the certification lounge.
Tonight and for the
rest of the week
we have hands on
labs over there.
Hands on labs are
free labs where you
can work through an experience.
Tonight we have late night
labs with beverages included.
We also have over
next to the hands
on lab area spotlight
labs where you
can work through a lab
with an instructor.
And if there's an area that
you're having trouble with,
sometimes watching
an instructor is
helpful to see how
they work through some
of the pieces of the lab.
Also tonight we have four
sessions of our very popular
cloud hero challenge lab.
So that's a lab
where you compete
to solve problems
against the clock
and your other
competitors for prizes.
We're going to have
four sessions of that.
And that's pretty fun.
So look for cloud hero
on your mobile app.
Finally, we do have a
couple of offers for free.
I think is it on here?
Yeah.
We have a couple of offers
for free time on Qwiklabs
and Coursera.
So using those links,
you can get access
to free Coursera and
Qwiklabs for a month.
That's pretty awesome.
If you have any questions
about any of this,
you can ask the people
over by the spotlight labs
and they'll give
you some pointers.
And if there's any
time left, I think
Dan's going to be around
for questions or I will too.
And we'll just stand over here.
Thank you.
MIKE TRUTY: Great.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]